There are some shark species that seem to do okay in aquariums.
You'll see a lot of nurse sharks, zebra sharks, some reef sharks...
...and sand tiger sharks, but not the great white.
For decades, aquariums have tried to contain the world's largest predatory fish.
Institutions like Marineland, SeaWorld and the Steinhart Aquarium...
...repeatedly took in white sharks during the 1970s, 80s and 90s,...
...at times drawing huge crowds, but they never lasted long.
Some needed help swimming.
None of them would eat.
The longest one lasted was just 16 days.
A 1984 report by the Steinhart Aquarium put it this way:...
..."In most cases, it could be said that all of these captive sharks...
...were merely in the process of dying, with some taking longer than others."
They had constructed an elaborate transport tank with a harness and IV fluids...
...but still couldn't keep the sharks alive.
It wasn't until 2004 that the Monterey Bay Aquarium...
...proved that it was possible to keep white sharks for at least six months.
It took a massive effort, and no one's done it since.